donc dans les colonnes du parisien on
apprenait que france télévisions avait
pris la décision de ne pas renouveler
leurs animateurs l'année prochaine sur
son compte
patrick sébastien a réagi pour la
première fois on regarde qu'après
j'aimerais avoir l'avis aussi de vincent
moscato parce que vincent
mais non vous êtes assez proche de lui
et moi je vais vous dire quel est mon
sentiment et après ma petite enquête je
vais vous dire pourquoi je pense que
france télévisions avait déjà en tête
depuis longtemps de d'évincer patrick
sébastien salut tout le monde je voulais
vous remercier pour les nombreux
messages de soutien que vous m'avez
envoyé à propos de mon éviction
programmée de france 2 va la femme d'à
saison je voulais vous dire que je ne
ferai aucun commentaire jusqu'à samedi
parce que samedi j'ai décidé de faire un
interview avec mon ami thierry ardisson
dans l'émission les terriens du sun
alors si vous voulez en savoir un petit
peu plus sur les vraies tenant et les
vrais ça petit cent de tout ça rendez
vous samedi à 19h30 dans les terriers du
samedi à hull thierry ardisson alors
voilà donc il l'a dit donc voilà il est
il a l'air en forme un patrick bien sûr
alors je voulais dit si vous nous
rejoignez ça s'est passé en cinq minutes
nana la femme de patrick sébastien qui
le conseil a été convoqué jeudi dernier
dans les bureaux de france télévisions
pour lui annoncer qu'il ne prolongerait
pas patrick sébastien ils ont même pas
convoqué patrick qu'ils ont provoqué sa
femme et le rendez vous je vous lis a
duré cinq minutes et pas de convocation
pour patrick sébastien c'est vrai que
voilà semblerait donc patrick sébastien
tourner son cabaret du mois de mai
demain ils souhaiteraient ensuite épuisé
et tout va finir toutes ses dernières
émissions
dans la foulée pour peigne pour finir ce
qu'il a à faire avec france télévisions
avant la fin de l'année comme ça
terminée et il est tranquille vous voyez
moi jénine pas choqué non parce que déjà
c'est le rôle d'une direction d'une
grande chaîne campagne d'un grand groupe
comme france télévisions de rajeunir en
permanence les grilles de programmes
et donc ça c'est quand même un programme
qui depuis très longtemps imaginé de
reprogrammer d'enfin de changer c'est
pas c'est pas un drame
nos deux géraldine tu dis que le monde
cruel très médiatiques ou nicolas qui a
dit que c'était très violent
c'est le monde du travail qui est très
violent et ouvriers
métallurgie ou cas de la banque on se
fait virer ces traîtres avions souvent
plus qu'on n'a pas le même cela fait
peur on est on si à dire mais le patrick
sébastien entouré de 64 ans voilà c'est
pas un âge ont plu aux principes du
travail est certainement ici veut
s'arrêter sur ce sont quatre ans il fera
comme il le chante une petite pique et
au lit et puis voilà il ya pas de
problème on l'a vu matters il a une vie
d'artiste avec des passages à catane
qu'honnêtement je pense que dans quai de
sébastien la vérité elle est la suivante
c'est que effectivement ça marche moins
bien
les émissions sont très chères il ya un
plan d'économies et c'est pas une
question de vieux pas mieux c'est que
dans le cadeau vous n'êtes pas choquer
bah non parce qu'effectivement
l'économie de la chaîne et part parce
que ça coûte et par rapport à l'audience
qui fait qui est certes encore correct
mais qui est largement en baisse par
rapport à être deux trois quatre cinq
ans il lance un chantage à la chaîne
avec des scores en baisse c'est
compliqué cyril alors je suis pas
d'accord avec vous mais c'est celui qui
est les meilleurs scores dans les
bêtises non non on fait les stomatites
messieurs play 12 en moyenne s'il vous
plaît il fait le double de ce qu'ils ont
fait samedi soir là un message il me
mais je vous aime mais je me protège
contre moi à la semaine prochaine donc
il ya un noir 40 des ter mate le trou
vulgaire pardon ça va plus on fait de la
populaire et vous le dirai a répondu que
les services publics il a passé beaucoup
d'années pour tf1 c'est un homme de
télévision quand il met en avant de
jeunes martyrs suédé arty lessard voyage
dans le temps qu'à paris mais des jeunes
chanteurs avec des chanteurs plus
algérie dans les années bonheur c'est le
service public est vrai pas d'accord
gilles je trouve que benjamin et
jean-michel disent des choses honteuses
même parce que franchement mais de quel
droit vous dites ça castagne et vous
savez vous avez été virés vous savez la
douleur que c'est pour lui c'est
terrible en ce moment là je trouve que
vous le piétiner je t'explique un
chantage qui le temps il a tenté avec
une chaîne à vous êtes en difficulté
vous dira t il à une tempête chantage en
début en début de saison tout seul alors
qu'il commence sa saison il dit voilà si
j'ai pas plus je m'en vais la chaîne le
prend au mot alors score je vois pas je
suis horrifié la braderie s'est exprimé
du chantage en permanence c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de chantage hélas la chaîne a
dit il mais ça lui chante avec cette
grosse qu'elle s'est passée dans et qui
voulaient réduire toutes les émissions
un moment il a dit pourquoi on me réduit
mes émissions alors je marche alors il y
en a d'autres sur le service public qui
ont des émissions qui ne marche pas
il avait 14 émissions par an pendant des
années dont la celle du 31 en plus ces
deux best of l'été aujourd'hui fait
cette émission après écosystème en tant
que producteur ne tient plus vous ne
pouvez pas avoir une stabilité du marché
tout est parti d'un article dans télé
star d'une interview qu'il a accordée il
ya quinze jours qui est sorti la semaine
dernière disait quoi où le journaliste
traduit les propos de patrick sébastien
comme un ultimatum à la chaîne d'accord
c'est ça la vraie chantal et lui non ça
un peu comme le firent la gaffe mais lui
ne l'a pas posé de cette manière
pour ça rien non non non non non alors
quand moi ça fait deux ça fait 12 ans
qu'on travaille ensemble
je connais un peu le garçon quand même
alors beaucoup d'heures ans oui j lui et
moi c'est un martyr de la gestion de
madame ernotte
et ce qui me choque c'est qu'on ne prend
jamais en compte le téléspectateur mais
madame ernotte être aussi donnons de
nous et nous nous voulons sébastien elle
fait n'importe quoi ça fait des mois je
vous dis que c'est la fossoyeuse du
service public et plein de charme ni
plomb voilà c'est franchement c'est
scandaleux
les gens veulent tirer là et on les voit
les audiences marche mieux puisqu'elle
est l'acheteur
alors oui c'est vrai qu'elle a un très
bon bilan dodemont moi je sais ce que je
pense je pense que france télévisions a
débarqué fin patrick sébastien parce
qu'ils ont un plan en tête je pense
qu'ils veulent remplacer patrick
sébastien parent qui par nikos je suis
personnellement il dit je pense qu'ils
l'ont déjà approché l'année dernière
nikos ils ont déjà fait des propositions
à nikos technique hausse sans trahir un
secret je pense que tf1 est lui ça se
passe bien mais c'est pas la grande
folie avec les grands patrons de tf1 en
ce moment il est à takis candilis qui
vient d'arriver qui est un grand ami
nikos qui est arrivé à la tête de france
télévisions ils sont très très proches
les deux c'était son patron à tf1 et si
lui il avait fait monter à tf1 à
l'époque je sais qu'ils en rêvent de
nikos aliagas pour les divertissements
de france 2 et je pense qu'ils préparent
le terrain pour beaucoup de volume pour
nikos l'année prochaine sur france 2
est-ce que je sors bernard montiel qui
me regardent et qui se dit il n'est pas
une connerie
je crois que vous avez entièrement
raison en fermant raison takis candilis
le rap était un des patrons comme on l'a
dit tout à l'heure de tf1 bon maintenant
c'est lui vraiment qui tient les rênes
financière d'ailleurs de france
télévisions puisque c'est même lui qui a
écarté également catherine ceylac d'ici
la fin de l'année
donc effectivement les copies très bons
en attaque issam il est excellent bien
super mais avec qui on a tous envie de
travailler et je pense que nikos a très
envie d'aller travailler avec takis
candilis qui est le nouveau patron de
france télé des programmes et je vous
dis je pense qu'ils sont en train de
faire de la place pour nikos voile après
nico c'est ce qui va quitter tf1
mais je pense ce serait quand même nico
sur france 2 moi j'aurais aimé avoir
patrick sébastien et nico sur france 2
mais je pense que nico c'est une bonne
idée car cyril à l'époque on avait
travaillé sur un projet en interne qui
était de faire glisser des gens sur
france 3 mais de dire qu'on avait deux
chaînes complémentaires ça rame d'âge et
pourquoi ils me garderai pas patrick
dans ce cas là il ne mettrait pas sur
france 3 mais il était passé à neuf
alors voilà alors c'est assez c'est
assez frustrant quand on joue en équipe
b comme alors je vais vous dire qu'ils
nous aient lieu d'un arrosoir gagne tous
les samedis soirs expression dans la
série once troy carter
après je pense que là ils sont arrivés
je vous le dis un truc à bras de fer
avec patrick sébastien
voilà ils ont les plus grandes écoutes
on va le sortir
je pense que c'est c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé nous expliquez nous
expliquer que tu vires sébastien parce
que ça coûte cher il va pas me retourne
aux fraises tagada nikos à france 2
[Applaudissements]
c'est la relance des gens mais quand ce
jouet qui vient de porter sur alors j'ai
pas besoin que je pense que vos
histoires alors nicolaj avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour vous je pense
franchement que quand on veut garder un
animateur ont trouvé sur l'argent mais
bien sûr franchement regardez nous on a
voulu garder benhaim les fonds de
tiroirs mais on l'a trouvé mais je
voulais mais c'est vrai et je vous dis
ils ont un rêve c'est de faire venir
nikos
ils ont besoin je pense aussi je vous le
dis que laurent ruquier va partir de
france télévisions en fin de saison et
qu'il va aller dans le groupe m6 je
pense qu'il va voir le refonte totale de
france télévisions et surtout de france
2 michel drucker et voilà ils ont gardé
parce que michel drucker il fait de
l'audience
et mine de rien c'était compliqué je
vous le dis le nouveau contrat de michel
drucker avec france télévisions et là
aussi voulait faire de la place encore
pour nikos donc voilà je vous dis je
pense qu'il ya des choses qui sont en
train de bouger à france télé et je suis
en train de préparer l'avenir est là
prêt voilà alors patrick sébastien moi
il ya plein de gens qui m'ont dit alors
est ce que patrick va venir sur wii la
wii cyril déjà qu'est ce que vous pensez
l'avenir pour patrick sébastien
dites-nous qu'est ce que vous voyez
comme mademoiselle à moi direct
franchement sur ces 8 vient c'est pas à
revoir
c'est par hasard non plus qu'ils aillent
chez ardisson il peut faire plein de
choses ici il peut faire du
divertissement
il peut être chez lui ça peut être sa
nouvelle maison moi j'y crois à fond et
je le souhaite alors on a beaucoup
d'animateurs sur s'est vite on n'a pas
ce genre à castaldi on à bernard montiel
on à la gaffe jamais pantalon on habille
nos affaires ni cordes il a un vrai
talent on sait que c'est pas un
animateur
c'est un artiste quelqu'un qui écrit qui
sait très bien écrire qui est prêt à
dire super bouquin qui sait écrire des
films qui s'est produit qu'est ce terme
comment il a le talent de l'art de vivre
vous étiez patron de conseil ou ce que
vous l'auriez prix sur ces 8 est ce que
j'aurais pris sur ses huit salles et
pont pour faire quoi si senna vont
refaire le cabaret non non mais est ce
que suppose que vous l'auriez prix sur
ces villes mais voilà on va travailler
sur des plans après ce qu'il faut voir
c'est l'audience de patrick sébastien
aussi est-ce que c'est l'audio ces
combats que de ses marques solides c'est
certain voilà c'est pas tout à fait même
public que france 2 oui je crois qu'ils
feraient ils feraient le programme de
trop s'ils continuent à télévision il
devrait être sur les routes de france à
la rencontre de son public
j'ai face à moi je verrais très bien en
tout va devoir satin blanc que
parcourent les routes à la rencontre de
son public avec un show qui leur
semblerait que vous ça serait top
alors justement vous dites que c'est un
showman moi je vous dire ce que j'en
pense de patrick sébastien sur ces huit
dans un instant vous avez vous également
de me donner votre avis mais regardez
c'est quelqu'un voilà qu'à plusieurs
cordes à son arc c'était à la base il
faut le savoir
patrick sébastien un imitateur à la
basse et un imitateur qui est devenu un
animateur regarder
et pourtant
le jour
tu réponds à trouille et on peut
déjeuner trop chaud les rues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
paul ii
les mots
alors vous est-ce que vous l'auriez des
récits vous étiez encore patron de
france télé dit la vérité
je pense que c'est une décision
compliquée arguant de répondre comme ça
mais juste un truc quand vous êtes
président de france télévisions c'est le
job le plus ingrat de la place parce que
vous l'auriez eh ben on à dépendre comme
ça je pourrai pas vous répondre
nicolas à la banque d'avoir ici le
problème de patrick c'est qu'il fait
quand même travailler des millions de
gens vous savez je pense que je l'aurais
pas fait mais en tout cas j'aurai je
l'aurais programmées ailleurs peut-être
le mardi soir maintenant que c'est la
semaine des quatre jours pour les
enfants d'accord mais là il aurait alors
moi je vous dirai ce que vous voyez sur
ces vies tout patrick sébastien vincent
moscato
pour benjamin non pas forcément pourquoi
pourquoi parce que moi je pense
qu'effectivement je pense que le style
mais je pense que patrick c'est vraiment
un homme de scène et je pense qu'il va
être très heureux d'aller rencontrer ces
six espère vraiment que c'est un homme
décède alors il m'a bien dit un patrick
sébastien sachez le
maintenant je pense qu'il a encore envie
de s'amuser à la télévision il ya 64 ans
patrick moi la réponse que je peux vous
donner
je vais vous dire déjà première chose
patrick vraiment pour moi je me
considère comme un ami
et s'il a vraiment envie voilà de
revenir à la télé s'il a besoin de
joleil bien sûr je le ferai parce que
voilà j'ai toujours les amis et que je
l'aimais énormément et qu'il a toujours
été là pour moi si maintenant vous me
dites pour moi est-ce qu'il a sa place
sur ces vite pour moi c'est un énorme
talent franchement voilà c'est un énorme
talent ça fait partie des dix animateurs
les plus emblématiques de la télévision
française depuis sa création donc
forcément un talent doit travailler en
télé et je pense qu'il a encore de
belles années devant lui et qu'il a
encore plein d'idées et qu'il est très
créatif mine de rien patrick après il
faut trouver le bon projet mais en tout
cas moi je le dis je suis pas fermé
maintenant c'est pas moi le vous le
savez le patron de ses beats donc
peut-être qu'il va voir la direction de
ses mythes et après il verra avec eux
s'ils se trouvent et c8 souza le
cimetière des éléphants oui les
animateurs du paf conclure qu'ils
regardent
impressionné il vaut mieux après faut
trouver le bon format le bon projet pour
la bonne personne voilà patrick voilà
s'il faut trouver le bon truc je le
mettrais pas voilà la présentation de
tpm paix comme comme benjamin peut le
faire où il dresse dans des émissions d
d'imitateur ou du variétés présentées
des jeunes talents présenter des
émissions qu'il ya des gens qui viennent
dans ces deux zones et vous carnaval
carnaval est morte à des jeunes venus
déguisés qui pouvait alors fait pas trop
alors pourquoi faire des trucs comme ça
regardez on va voir le sondage sur
patrick sébastien patrick sébastien
animateur sur ces vies de bonnes idées
47% mauvaise idée
53% à la cave vous voyez non ils ont
peur de la gaffe ils viendront de
l'agaci c'est pour qu'ils viennent pour
qu'il fasse encore trois émissions il va
m'entendre dire en compte en france 2
ils vont le rappeler il va repartir en
france
[Applaudissements]